nine-year-old zadine mirai has been
asking about his bicycle since the early
hours of the morning with the help of a
friend he managed to find what's left of
it
the mirahi family says the only thing
they're left with now is their memories
of 25 years after israeli forces blew up
their house early on tuesday
the israeli military arrested yahya
mirai and his cousin yusef rasi in late
april both men are in their early 20s
and the israeli military accuses them of
killing a guard of an illegal israeli
settlement in the occupied west bank
after their arrest the family was
expecting the house to be demolished so
they took out some of their belongings
what they couldn't prepare for is to see
their house in ruins
i wanted to take my books clothes and
toys but they didn't let me israel has
long implemented the policy of
demolishing houses belonging to
palestinian suspects accused of killing
israelis
my son is a hero it wasn't easy for him
to see what the occupation did during
ramadan the events in al-aqsa
particularly affected him
earlier on tuesday israeli forces
demolished the house of yusuf asi as
well homeless now the asi family are
staying with relatives
the israeli decision is that we can't
rebuild here for five to fifteen years
this land is confiscated
i have a plot here for joseph will build
on for now we are scattered in relatives
homes
the israeli government says house
demolitions are meant to prevent future
attacks but human rights organizations
say since palestinian attackers are
often killed or imprisoned it's their
families
who end up being punished
the occupied west bank